HUNTER WILLIAMS: So a little
bit of background on myself.
I, as Bill mentioned, was on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
I don't come from the
media and content side.
I come from the cloud
technology side.
So when Kevin reached out
to me earlier this year
and asked me to come and join
the team as they spun off
this business, I was
really excited to go
on to the buy side
of cloud computing
and see how things are
from the other side.
So I joined about
two months ago.
I came from the Google
Cloud Sales Team,
previously with RightScale.
Most my focus in
that world had been
on media and entertainment,
gaming as well.
So I knew a lot of the
people in the industry,
but it was really
exciting to get
to join an actual studio that
was building a cloud product.
So I want to talk a little bit
about how Atomic Fiction uses
Conductor and then ultimately
how Conductor uses GCP.
And to start, I want to talk
a little bit about the history
of Atomic Fiction.
So in 2009, Kevin
Baillie and Ryan Tudhope
founded Atomic Fiction.
They were alumni from IMD,
which is a Disney company
or was a Disney company.
And they were also at
Lucas for quite some time.
When they founded
the company, they
wanted to build a business
around new technologies that
had just come out.
So they were using the cloud.
At the time they were
using Zync Render,
as Todd talked about earlier.
But as the company
grew, and now that it's
125 employees, two locations--
well, three locations,
I guess, if you count
the LA office-- the needs
of the business changed.
And so they decided, as
many different studios do,
to build their own
render pipeline.
But they were going to
build this render pipeline
in the cloud.
So enter Conductor.
They hired a guy
from DreamWorks who
had built very large-scale
render farms before,
and he came in and built
out a product on GCP
that took advantage of that
minute-by-minute billing,
the fast boot up times,
the fast shutdown times.
They could just
simply deploy whatever
they needed as far
as a render farm was
concerned in under a minute.
So how does Atomic
Fiction use Conductor?
We use it for
rendering on demand.
So submit a job, artist--
as Todd mentioned,
artists are expensive.
You don't want them
sitting there and waiting
for any period of time.
So once they submit
their job, we
want to get that back to
them as quickly as possible.
So especially with
high-priority jobs,
we'll just default map a single
frame to a single instance.
One of the great things
that we love about Google
is the sheer size of it.
So if we want to
deploy 1,000 instances,
we can do that in
under 10 minutes.
We can then run those for
maybe 1,000 frame sequence,
and then shut those down
with a 10-minute minimum,
say 11 minutes later.
And then all of this plugs
into the Shotgun's cloud
solution, which is
a great product.
We love using it.
We're doing some
deeper integrations
with Conductor and
Shotgun as well
that will allow us to
feed data back and forth.
We're currently pulling
data out of Shotgun,
but we'd love to push
some data back into it
around how much does a
shot costs to render?
How many times have
you rendered it,
and what is the total
cost of that to date?
And so a little bit about
how Conductor uses you GCP
and why we love it.
So we use Compute Engine
for our render farm,
as I'm sure most of you know.
But the things that we really
like about Compute Engine
are, first and foremost
the permitability.
We were on Amazon
through Zync when
they were on Amazon before.
And we saw a lot of waste.
An average frame for us takes 37
minutes to render using Katana,
so if we only run that
instance for 37 minutes,
we waste the last 23
minutes of that hour.
With Google's platform
rollout, we're
able to run it for
just that 37 minutes,
shut it down, not
worry about it anymore.
Next is cloud storage
and persistent disk.
So we use cloud storage in
their Nearline archival system
to back up used assets,
to back up old assets,
to store pretty much
anything that we upload.
And it's become, for Atomic,
our single source of truth.
The minute we use persistent
disk with a custom NFS set up,
also some glusters, as
you guys have heard today,
to do our file serving.
It works really well.
We have yet to hit
a ceiling with it.
I'm going to walk through a
pretty detailed example of how
we've done this on our
most recent project,
and you'll see that we spike it
pretty high a couple of times.
So a little bit about Conductor.
So Conductor is a new product.
It's pre-release.
You can go online and sign
up to join the private beta.
We're happy to have you.
You're going to get
a phone call from me
right after that happens.
We designed it with
the artists in mind.
We've gotten a lot of guidance
from the Atomic Fiction team.
It's great to have a
really tight feedback loop
with coming out of a studio.
The artists are really the ones
that we want to cater to here.
So we've built tools
to integrate with NUKE,
to integrate with Autodesk
or with Maya, to integrate
with other products
in the industry,
V-Ray is another great one.
And we just want to integrate
it in such a simple way
that an artist can build
their scene and click
render in the cloud.
Send it to Conductor.
And then we give those
artists a really simple UI
so they can go in and
see if jobs are pending,
if they're uploading,
if they're completing,
maybe view some
log files if they
want to do some of their
own troubleshooting.
And then for the render
wranglers and the admins
out there, we build
tools that make
the troubleshooting process
just that much easier.
So we have complex
job management tools.
You can update
priorities on the fly.
You can restart, kill, pause,
check the status of jobs.
You can build
automated workflows.
So as you start to build
priorities and things
into, say, Shotgun
software, you can make sure
when a job goes to the cloud
that a high-priority one drops
right into a queue and
starts going right away.
And then for the finance
and operations folks,
this is one of the
things that we're
going to talk about in
the next couple of slides.
It's an interesting thing.
Cloud costs have always been
considered really opaque.
And a lot of people have been
concerned about runaway costs,
IT leakage, people
launching instances and not
shutting them down, people
storing stuff and not deleting
it, and really dealing
with runaway costs.
So one of the things
that we took really
seriously as we started doing
this was to focus on how do we
want to present that data to the
artist, to the administrators,
to the finance people?
Is it on a daily basis?
Is it real time?
What we landed on is that
we use Google's BigQuery
service and Datastore.
So we have all sorts
of bread crumbs
in our code to be
able to track when
it's launched, what shop
they were associated with,
what they were doing.
And we feed all of that data
into a huge table that we then
can build dashboards
around so you
can see this show
by shot by artist,
and slice that data in a
lot of different directions.
So I want to talk through
a real-world example here,
because I think that's
probably the best
way to talk about
cloud costs as compared
with maybe a more traditional
data center approach.
So the most recent
project that we finished
was Bob Zemeckis's
"The Walk." "The Walk"
is the story of Philippe Petit
who walked between the Twin
Towers in the 1970s with
no safety equipment,
for those of you who have not
seen it or heard about it.
As you would imagine, this took
quite a lot of visual effects
time, because the New York
skyline looks a lot different
than it did in 1970.
So we had to recreate all of
the background, the towers, all
of that for 37 minutes worth of
visual effects for this movie.
So it did take quite
a lot of render hours.
It took just over
500,000, in fact,
which is 87 years
worth of rendering time
on a single node.
This is all done on 16 core
instances for our rendering,
32s now that they're out.
And we are also doing
a lot of our comping
now on smaller instances,
taking advantage
of just the full gamut
that Google has to offer.
So you look at our cycle here.
So we started off--
you know, the months
are somewhat arbitrary,
but asset creation, poorly
optimized renders.
That's what that early ramp is.
Months three, four, and five
are October, November, December.
So that's the holiday dip.
People are not working
for half the month.
This year was especially.
Everybody had about
two weeks off.
And then you see us ramp
way back up into production
and peak out there with
quite a lot of render hours
in what was March.
Then you can see it drops
back down to almost 0.
And then this now,
this new month, it
is all the way down
to 0 for this project.
So zooming in on March alone,
because that was really
our big spike month, over
the whole course of the film,
we used 9.1 million core hours.
We're normalizing some
this data into core hours,
because we used difference
instance types and things
like that.
But in March alone, we
used almost three million
core hours.
You can see this is
on a day-by-day basis
the breakdown of
our render process.
So sort of a normal
two-week cycle.
Then you see a big
spike as we started
getting into the final
film reviews with Bob.
And then you see
one big spike, which
was the night before
our big film review,
where we had to render a whole
bunch of shots and scenes
and do a whole bunch of comping
in that particular case.
You see it drops back down.
That was the day of the meeting.
We got some notes,
spikes back up.
And then it goes down as we
deliver the final project.
Coming from the cloud
space for a long time,
this is like the perfect
use case for cloud.
You could own the
infrastructure, but where do
you own for?
Do you own for
the two big spikes
there in the middle and deal
with some delay for the bigger
one?
Well, that would have meant,
in our particular case,
that the shots wouldn't have
been ready for their film
review at 9:00 AM.
So the cloud is
an obvious choice.
So we had a maximum spike
to over 1,000 nodes.
A couple interesting
stats on that.
It took us about 12 minutes
to launch all those nodes.
That was pretty impressive
from my perspective,
when I was watching
it that evening,
watching the number bounce up.
And during our common peaks,
not just in this month
but in other months as well,
we see around 500 nodes.
So for sake of evaluation as
we go through some of the cost
comparisons here, we actually
took it below 500 to 400 nodes
to do a cost comparison,
because at 500, it just
didn't make any sense to buy
that many if you're only going
to be working on one project.
So this is Conductor's
cost curve.
So this is for
Atomic's actual costs.
These are actual rack rate
bills straight out of our system
that we sent to Atomic.
You can see that it mimics very
similarly that curve that we
showed in the previous slide.
But you can also see that
the monthly loaded cost
of supporting 400 nodes, for
most of the months there,
it's significantly higher
than what they actually
would have needed.
Now, this doesn't
take into account
the fact that we were
working on other projects
at the same time, and there
is some overlap there.
But if we go back
and we analyze what
we need, when we need to
hit spikes at the same time,
when we have production
deadlines that overlap,
we think that this is
a pretty fair estimate
of how much we would
have had to spend
on an actual infrastructure.
So here are some summary
notes on this example.
We used 9.1 million core
hours, spiked over 1,000 nodes.
With local
infrastructure, if we had
tried to support
some of those spikes
with some
optimizations added, we
would have ended up at
30% average utilization.
That's a pretty gross number.
You don't want to ever
see that in a data center,
but it's sort of a reality
of the fairly cyclical work
that we all do.
We estimate, by subtracting
those two previous graphs
together or from each other,
we saved about $800,000
on this show alone.
That's a pretty big number.
When we look at the bids, that
makes us much more competitive
than some of the other studios
that are out there offering
similar-style visual effects.
A lot of this we have
to thank Google for.
I mean, billing by the
minute, that's amazing.
We obviously would
not be able to achieve
any of these sorts of numbers
with hourly billing at Amazon.
The hardware is
delivered on demand.
If you compare this to
a three-year buy cycle,
you have to buy
hardware and you're not
going to be able to
get updates on it.
Google updates their
hardware all the time.
So you're constantly getting
the latest and greatest,
better network performance,
better servers.
As things start to go obsolete,
they're already updating them.
And then the global footprint.
So we have offices
in Montreal that
are doing rendering--
Montreal and Oakland.
So being able to
have this happen
in the middle of
the country where
we can do caching between
the two with Avere,
and allow Google to be
our single source of truth
that we pull any texture,
color, dependency down from
to do work on is amazing.
And the fact that Google's
network is so vast
allows that to happen
really seamlessly.
So I want to wrap up
with a little bit of talk
on where we see the
future of the cloud going.
We see further democratization
of these resources and easier
access.
We're seeing,
through partnerships
that Google is
forging, that we're
forging with some of the
vendors in the industry,
that there's an appetite to
do cloud-based licensing.
So licensing as a service, pay
by the hour, pay by the minute,
pay by the second in some
of our partners' cases.
That's something that
wasn't there before.
So we want to help
lower the barrier
to entry so that people
can get on the cloud
and can set these farms up
and do their work easier.
At least in our case, we
already see cost savings.
We know through a lot
of the discussions
that we've had that people have
done a whole lot of analysis
on this, and they don't
think the savings are there.
We believe that they are,
and we're passing those
through to our customers,
or Atomic Fiction
is in their bids.
Our bids are very
cost competitive
and significantly lower than
a lot of the competition
out there.
And it allows us to afford
higher quality artists
so the end product ends up
being much higher quality.
And then in the long run, we
do see the entire workflow
moving to the cloud.
We've already got things like
Shotgun that's cloud-based.
People are starting to
rendering in the cloud.
But as technologies come
out for better compression
and for things like
that where we could
put artists' workstations
in the cloud,
we could put the full
render pipeline up there,
and be able to stream back
color-accurate scenes.
All of a sudden you
think about the industry
and how many people are moving
to Canada and to other areas
due to the tax
benefits, you'd be
able to create a
studio on demand
and simply give all of these
artists Chromebooks or MacBook
Airs with big high-def
monitors that they can use,
and you end up saving
a whole lot of money
on overhead by being
able to do that.
So with that, I'm going to be
around for next hour or so.
I know that I'm standing between
you guys and a delicious Google
lunch.
So come ask questions.
I'm happy to chat.
You can find out more
information about Conductor
by going to renderconductor.com
and signing up for our beta.
Happy to get in touch
and chat with you
about what we're doing.
And thank you very much.